hey everyone welcome back to our Channel
today we have got an exciting topic for
all you aspiring machine learning
engineers and data science Enthusiast
out there we will be diving into the
world of algorithms discussing the top
10 algorithms every machine learning
engineer should know and whether you are
a beginner or a Season Pro this video is
packed with Essential Knowledge that
will elevate your machine learning game
so without without any further Ado let's
get started and before we move on if you
want to become an AI or ml expert and
gain handsome salary packages look at a
wide range of AI ml courses offered by
simply learn in collaboration with top
universities and that is across the
globe so by enrolling in any of these
certification programs you will gain
expertise in skills like generative AI
prompt engineering chat jbt explainable
AI machine learning algorithm supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and and optimization and there's much
more on the list with hands-on
experience in tools like chat jpt d
python open CV and tensor flow you will
catch ey on top recruiters so what are
you waiting for hurry up and enroll now
and a year of experience is prefer to
enroll in these courses you can find the
course Link in the description box below
and pin comment so without further Ado
let's jump into the topic and first
we'll start with the types of machine
learning algorithms so machine learning
algorithms are classified into four
types and that is supervised
unsupervised semi-supervised and
reinforcement learning so we'll just
have a brief on all these types so first
is supervised learning so supervised
learning is a machine learning approach
where algorithms learn from labeled data
the algorithm receives input data and
corresponding correct output labels in
the process and the objective is to
train the algorithm to predict accurate
labels for new unseen data an example of
supervised learning algorithms include
decision trees support Vector machines
random Forest na based algorithm and
these algorithms can be used for
classification regression and time
series forecasting task now coming to
unsupervised learning in this machine
learning approach algorithms analyze
unlabeled data without predefined output
labels and the objective is to discover
patterns relationships all structures
within the data and now so the common
unsupervised learning techniques include
clustering algorithms like K means
hierarchical clustering dimensionality
reduction methods like PCA and PSN and
now coming to semisupervised learning so
semisupervised learning is a hybrid
machine learning approach that combines
labeled and unlabelled data for training
it leverages The Limited label data and
larger set of unlabelled data to improve
the learning process the idea is that
the unlabeled data provide additional
information and context to enhance the
model's understanding and performance so
now we'll come to semisupervised
learning techniques that can be applied
to various tasks such as classification
regression and anomaly detection that
allow models to make more accurate
predictions and generalize better in
real world scenarios now coming to the
fourth type that is reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is a
machine learning algorithm inspired by
how humans learn from trial and error
here an agent interacts with an
environment and learns to make optimal
decisions maximize cumulative rewards
the agent receives feedback through
Rewards or penalties based on its action
and the agent learns to take actions
that lead to the most favorable outcomes
over time so this Dynamic approach to
learning makes reinforcement learning a
powerful technique for tackling complex
decision-making problems and now let's
kick things off by understanding why
these algorithms are so crucial machine
learning algorithms are the heart and
soul of AI they are the tools that
enable computers to learn from data and
make Intelligent Decisions so mastering
these top 10 algorithms will give you a
solid foundation in machine learning so
now we'll start with the machine
learning algorithms so we'll just get a
brief of all the algorithms that every
machine learning engineer should know so
number number one on our list is linear
regression it's the goto algorithm for
understanding the relationship between
variables making it fundamental and
predictive modu we'll dive deep into
workings and practical applications so
to understand the working functionality
of linear regression imagine how you
would arrange random logs of wood in
increasing order of their weight there
is a catch however you cannot weigh each
log you have to guess its weight just by
looking at the height and girth of the
log and arranging them using a
combination of these visible parameters
this is what linear regression in
machine learning is like in this process
a relationship is established between
independent and dependent variables by
fitting them to a line this line is
known as the regression line and is
represented by a linear equation that is
y = a into x + B and in this equation Y
is dependent variable a is slope X is
independent variable and B is intercept
the co ient of A and B are derived by
minimizing the sum of the square
difference of distance between data
points and the regression line and now
coming to the second algorithm that is
logistic regression so logistic
regression is used to estimate discrete
values usually binary values like 0 or 1
from a set of independent variables it
helps predict the probability of an
event by fitting data into a logit
function it is also called logit
regression these methods listed below
are often used to help improve logistic
regression models that is include
interaction terms eliminate features
regularize techniques and use a
nonlinear model so this was about
logistic regression now moving to the
next algorithm that is decision tree
decision tree algorithm in machine
learning is one of the most popular
algorithm in used today this is a
supervis learning algorithm that is used
for classifying problems it works well
in classifying both categorical and
continuous dependent variables this
algorithm divides the population into
two or more homogeneous sets based on
the most significant attributes or
independent variables so this was about
the decision 3 algorithm now moving to
the next algorithm that is svm support
Vector machine algorithm so svm
algorithm is a method of a
classification algorithm in which you
plot row data as points in an N
dimensional space space where n is the
number of features you have the value of
each feature is then tied to a
particular coordinate making it easy to
classify the data lines fold classifiers
can be used to split the data and Float
them on a graph so this was about
support Vector machine algorithm now mov
to the next algorithm that is Nave base
algorithm a na Bas classifier assumes
that the presence of a particular
feature in a class is unrelated to the
presence of any other feature even if
these featur fees are related to each
other a na based classifier would
consider all of these properties
independently when calculating the
probability of a particular outcome a na
basan model is easy to build and useful
for massive data sets it's simple and is
known to outperform even highly
sophisticated classification methods so
this was about NBAs algorithm now mov to
the next algorithm that is KNN K nearest
neighbors algorithm so this algorithm
can can be appli to both classification
and regression problems apparently
within the data science Industry it's
more widely used to solve classification
problems it's a simple algorithm that
stores all available cases and
classifies any new cases by taking a
majority V of its K neighbors the case
is then assigned to the class with which
it has the most in common a distance
function performs this measurement pnn
can be easily understood by comparing it
to real life for example if you want
information about a person it makes
sense to talk to his or her friends and
colleagues things to consider before
selecting K nearest neighbor algorithm
number one K&N is computationally
expensive number two variable should be
normalized or else higher range
variables can bias the algorithm third
data still needs to be pre-processed so
this was about the K&N the K nearest
neighbors algorithm now moving to the
next algorithm that is K means algorithm
it is an unsupervised learning algorithm
that solves clustering problems data
sets are classified into a particular
number of clusters let's call that
number K in such a way that all the data
points within a cluster are homogeneous
and heterogeneous from the data in other
clusters how K means forms clusters the
K means algorithm picks K number of
points called centroids for each cluster
and each data point forms a cluster with
the closest centroids that is K clusters
it now creates new centroids based on
the existing cluster members with these
new centroids the closest distance for
each data point is determined this
process is repeated until the centroids
do not change so this was about keans
algorithm now moving to the next
algorithm That Is Random Forest
algorithm Collective of decision trees
is called a random Forest to classify a
new object based on its attributes each
tree is classified and the tree boards
for that class the forest chooses the
classification having the most ws and
each tree is planted and grown as
follows if the number of cases in the
training set is n then a sample of n
cases is taken at random and this sample
will be the training set for growing the
tree and if there are M input variables
a number M less than m is specified such
that each node that is M variables are
selected at random out of the m and the
best split of this m is used to split
the node the value of M is held constant
during the process and each tree is
grown to the most substantial extent
possible there's no pring this was about
the random Forest algorithm and now
moving to the next algorithm that is
dimensionality reduction algorithm in
today's world vast amounts of data are
being stored and analyzed by corporates
government agencies and research
organizations as a data scientist you
know that this row data contains a lot
of information that is the challenge is
to identify significant patterns and
variables and the dimensionality
reduction algorithms like decision Tre
factor analysis missing value ratio and
random Forest can help you find relevant
details so this was about dimensionality
reduction algorithms now moving to the
last algorithm that is gradient boosting
algorithm and add a boosting algorithm
so gradient boosting algorithm are
boosting algorithms used when massive
loads of data have to be handled to make
predictions with high accuracy boosting
is an ensemble learning algorithm that
combines the predictive power of several
base estimators to improve robustness in
short it combines multiple weak or
average predictors to build a strong
predictor these boosting algorithms
always work well in data science
competitions like Gaggle AV hecaton
croud analytics and these are the most
preferred machine learning algorithms
studing use them along with python and R
codes to achieve accurate outcomes so
this was all about the top 10 machine
learning algorithms that every machine
learning engineer should know and
remember mastering these algorithms will
provide you with a solid foundation to
tackle various machine learning problems
and if you found this video helpful
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to our channel for more exciting content
thank you for watching and until next
time happy learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here